the penultimate question is a favorite
quote of mine from the great thinker
writer Soren Kierkegaard who said that
life can only be understood backwards
but you must live it forwards and I'm
curious for you what aspect of life in
your 20s was mysterious fraught with
fear perilous seem mysterious that now
you look back through the telescope of
time and I knew and you have clarity
that you'd like to communicate to that
former version of yourself you know I
think if I could have said anything to
myself in my 20s if I could meet myself
in my 20s and CG I can do it now so I'm
sure some but some of the me makers will
be will be on it ASAP I think you see
it's interesting because I don't have
any regrets truly it's not to say I
haven't made mistakes along the way but
I think overall the mistakes were just
part of the tapestry that led to
something good that led to something
with purpose and all that so I don't I
don't have regrets in a traditional
sense but I perhaps wish that I had been
a little bit easier on myself I think I
would have told myself to take a breath
that this whole thing has happened
before and it's gonna happen again
and and be more accepting of my flaws
and my faults and to really bring it
back to the beginning of the book you
know you know I did a lot of stuff that
I'm not proud of when I was in the
closet and it's hard to live one life
much less two or three um and I think I
would have I would have done things
differently if I could have and I would
have maybe sat myself down and said hey
listen you can either be yourself or you
can see what's gonna happen and I think
most people and it has nothing to do
with sexuality it's like be yourself
that's the message
you